j'aime pas être un type négligé une
question mal tout ça c'est féminable un
homme comme ça ça n'a aucune valeur
j'ai fait les 22 ans de tous les jours
j'ai 58 ans
et puis je suis venu ici comme je suis
seul j'ai plus de famille
j'étais abandonné très jeune
c'était mieux récitation publique de
l'an à l'âge de 8 ans et demi
donc c'est
[Musique]
toujours devant
je suis né
différent de vous
je n'ai rien de ma composition
de mes organes rien comme vous
je suis né avec le coeur à droite le
foie
d'être là et là la rate au lieu d'être
là elle est là
tout différent de vous
comme mention ils ont mis celui qui me
l'a trouvé il a mis en versement total
des organes
puis l'oublier c'est ça une communauté
de 170 hommes hors norme puis Louviers
voudrait surtout être en face entre
l'armée et la vie civile une simple
étape pour des hommes qui depuis des
années non plus pour solfamilles que la
légion
Gaby est arrivé à piloubier il y a 10
ans après l'Algérie colvésie mais c'est
dans le civil qu'il a essuyé ses plus
cinglants échecs à 55 ans Gaby sait
qu'il finira ses jours ici la vie dehors
c'est dure
je vous le dis c'est très dur
tu es mon meilleur copain
et vous vous n'avez pas peur de la mort
non pas tellement
ça t'arrive n'importe comment n'importe
quand
[Musique]
pas être un type négligé une question
mal tout ça c'est minable un homme comme
ça ça n'a aucune valeur une homme qui
tient
négligée mal
parasit ou mal habillé tout ça je trouve
que c'est pas par des hommes un vrai
homme il sait se tenir vraiment comme un
homme
que tout soit au millimètre près
et j'ai toujours roulé ma couverture de
cette façon voilà on l'attire on la
prend bien on l'attend bien et aussitôt
on arrive à donner une aspect militaire
à notre à notre lit un aspect militaire
un bon petit café ça me fera
du bien
j'ai besoin d'un petit remontant
pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes devenu
légionnaires
pas que je fais du mal à personne
une bêtise en dehors de des lois
humaines
non tout vient d'une femme
tout vient d'une femme
que j'adorais que j'aimais
et que vous avez perdu non je l'ai pas
perdu je l'ai pas perdu
et a eu beaucoup de complications et à
la ferme mais ça n'a pas marché
ça n'a pas marché moi j'ai eu tellement
une grande déception qui m'a tellement
touchée que je pouvais pas m'en remettre
et puis finalement un coup de tête et je
me suis engagé à la Légion les
légionnaires n'ont pas que des histoires
d'amour tristes tous graines avec
plaisir le souvenir de ces femmes belles
et brunes croisées sous les tropiques
chroniques aime aussi le souvenir de
sesdames accueillantes qui font la vertu
des bordels qui c'est cette femme
c'était une femme qui semble un peu un
prostituée à Toulouse qui était
d'ailleurs la prostituée la plus belle
que je fréquentée par plusieurs années
tous les weekends mon premier semestre
était un ou deux bières pour pas trop
être trop agressif et ensuite un ou deux
fois l'amour bien fait comment on fait
avec tes prostituées et au parc et en X
comme on dit et voilà
mon tableau le bord approche
à la femme à la belle et elle les pousse
le repousse le mort et même lui-même il
recule il sait pas le moment encore à la
France
[Musique]
puis l'oublier est un bivouac définitif
à l'espace de 200 hectares où l'on
produit tout ce qui est nécessaire à
l'autosuffisance de la communauté chacun
y participe selon ses capacités
physiques
[Musique]
ces anciens légionnaires ressemblent à
des ermites à des naufragés qui
s'accrochent à leur passé alors culture
comme un ultime rempart
[Musique]
appuie Loubier on ne parle jamais
d'avenir l'avenir n'appartient plus à
ces hommes depuis longtemps déjà il
regarde le monde dehors selon leur
expression comme une terre qui leur est
aussi étrangère qui n'accessible
à combien de mètres vous voulez remettre
à 10 mètres 15 mètres
et la dernière fois que vous vous êtes
servis d'un pistolet c'était où
on sait pas qui c'est alors
on a fait siffler les balais
ça naturelle qui ne restait dans les
sites qu'on a fait lignes de Chine on
était dans les coins
[Musique]
c'est naturel que pour un voleur il peut
mettre les mines il peut mettre à
n'importe quoi là il rentre à n'importe
où
moi aussi j'ai peur de la force
je me suis coupé le bras
les hommes depuis Loubier sont comme les
autres hommes peuplés de souvenirs plus
ou moins bon
[Applaudissements]
à 87 ans Jean Massoni regrette toujours
qu'une femme lui est brisée le coeur
sans cette maudite à faire il serait
devenu
Fred Astaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
[Musique]